we had a campaign National progress
Alliance of an executive director months
and months before any of this happen
stuff happened this should be the
easiest ask on planet Earth give it to
the Humane Society give it to Dave Rubin
give it to my nonprofit give it give it
to to I don't need it give it to give it
to anybody give it to anybody but don't
give it to University because when you
give it to your University you're
supporting an indoctrination Mill you're
supporting something you're supporting
an institution who's very Val values are
antithetical to Western liberal
democracy so you have to
stop all right Peter B we are here I'm
not even going to say your full name
you're Peter B you've appeared on this
show so many times don't need a last
name who needs a last name but I know
we've had conversations over many years
before we met else you were half the man
you used to be you got off the dairy and
look at you you what you lost like 30
lbs or something well that's the crazy
thing is I mentioned the only change I
made literally the only change was I
took Dairy out of my diet and I just I
mean I could show you but it's little
like I could show it's a family I could
show you my my uh my pan Loop but but
the other thing is I kept every variable
the same so I scienced it so I know that
it I know that it had to be Dairy and I
feel great with the weight off Beyond
Dairy and diets which are very important
uh we have about 20 minutes here we're
at this this art conference and what we
are trying to do what Jordan is trying
to do is tell a better story so that the
West can save itself you've been one of
the guys out there at college campuses I
mean this is basically what you do for a
living now trying to show people that
maybe they don't necessarily know why
they believe what they believe what they
might be confused about right um do you
view that is kind of the first step
before we get to the course correction
is kind of pull pulling some of the the
strings on on what's wrong with people's
thinking I view it as a critical step I
don't I don't know if it's the first
step I think that the first step is that
our institutions are so corrupt right
now that and not it it's not just that
our institutions are corrupt and our
Legacy institutions are corrupt but it's
that we know that the Wellspring of this
is from Academia I mean we know that in
fact James Lindsay is in there
2015 we identifi the problem 2017 we
published on the conceptual blank yeah
um you can say penis oh I can say yeah
we published the whole we still allow to
say penis on YouTube you know we'll link
to that interview that that I did with
you guys about that people that don't
remember we put that yeah 2018 we
decided to do something about it
everyone thought we were crazy like
truly nut so it you know the trajectory
it's not happening it's only Fringe
Fringe people in Fringe departments it's
only Fringe departments it's only
Humanities it's only universities it
will never spill out here we are it
continues to get worse although now I I
see I think we're seeing a balance but
once
we the two pass to to ideological
capture of the institutions you build
new institutions or you try to reform
institutions and to santis is doing a
fantastic job at reform I'll be very
blunt with you I don't think it's going
to succeed but I completely 100% support
the mission um you don't think it's
going to see you meaning at at a succeed
at a national level at a national level
yeah well that that might be right I
think it from at the Florida level it
seems like it's working well rufo is
doing fantastic job at new College we
went to New college but back to your
original question we can talk about that
back to your original question is that
would you live in an echo chamber not
you but college campuses or Echo
Chambers students not only don't hear
the other side of the issue but they
think they're better people because they
don't so it's a an indoctrination Mill a
factory a social justice Factory and so
re and I go around not just the United
States States but the world and we do
Spectrum Street epistemology we put Mt
strongly disagree disagree slightly
disagree neutral on the other side and
we ask people targeted questions to see
if the confidence in their belief is
warranted and invariably as you can see
from literally I don't even know how
many videos now it's not the case I
suppose it doesn't surprise you at this
point in your career that the people who
seem more open to discussing these
things tend to lean a little more
conservative yeah I'm glad you didn't
say to the right uh they they lean right
these terms are all becoming sort of we
totally yeah yeah here's the other thing
I found is that invariably people in the
United States when you ask college kids
and you can see this all the videos
they're looking for reasons to be
offended they're looking to be upset but
when we do this here you don't you don't
see that you don't it's the feel is
different the tenor is different and we
know we've done Israeli Palestinian
problem we've done virtually every
transgressive problem one can think of
but this idea that I'm a good person
because I'm offended by this because I
don't even know I I've been
indoctrinated by my institution it's a
serious problem you you've been so in on
this not because of just what you do
publicly now but you were at Portland
State you were teaching you were
teaching ethics or philosophy philosophy
and ethics critical thinking yeah and
one one of the first public gings that I
ever did was you invited me up there
with Christina hops we had a great time
and it was the three of us but the
amount of security it was the first time
just telling some the the the people
with the shields we had to go into the
room and we were with Christina who I
remember she had the daintiest little
wrists and I remember think they were
screaming that we were Nazis and all
this stuff and how this woman couldn't
you know she's like the softest woman
you could possibly imagine they're
calling me a homophobe and you're a Nazi
and Andy know Andy know was just was
just in here and Andy know at that time
was a student there and now and now he's
obviously become a huge voice and all
this but I mention that because it's
like you were on the academic side now
you're on the other side of it you left
I mean I had to leave that's something I
mean you put your money where your mouth
yeah I had to leave they look look look
imagine just just imagine what we were
doing to students we were telling them
they were getting an education we were
doing them a disservice they weren't
getting an education they thought they
were being educated you know educar a to
lead out of they weren't getting that
and anyone who stayed in that system
basically perpetuated Injustice and
almost it it was almost criminal what we
were doing to those kids so Portland
State was the nucleation point before
the mass explosion like is's most easy
to see in Portland at Port Portland
State yeah and all the derangements
everything defund the police abolish
prisons all the total craziness by the
way Portland's murder rate has shot up
the police force is down to alltime low
I think there's only one traffic cop in
the whole city so you drive around
people do donuts in the street I mean
there were necessary
consequences to public policies so what
is the better story that's the other
question I'm asking everybody here since
that's the whole idea of the comments
what what is the better story other than
okay you know let's respect each other
no that's I'm sorry sorry sorry
about that I feel comfortable with our
demone doing um well one of the things
I've come to figure out what that is but
I have my own answer to the question but
I want to listen I genuinely want to
listen to to hear what other people have
to say here's my answer that's the
beauty of this by the way everyone's
presenting their own argument for this I
don't think anyone's coming here and
saying it's it's my way or high way yeah
well I I well I'm going to find out I'm
going to find out that's why that's why
I'm here here's my answer to that
Western values worth defending freedom
is worth defending Enlightenment values
freedom of the press F Association
freedom of speech I don't want another
eoch chamber I don't want to be in a
place where if I give a secular a
blasphemy a secular blasphemy or say
something heretical I want to hear
voices in the Israeli Israeli
Palestinian debate I want to hear you
know there people are screaming um Gast
to Jews now in um in Australia I don't
know if you've seen that those videos I
mean they're clear incitements to murder
right and so it's shifted from any kind
of public policies to attack on it the
people for who they are I think that we
have strayed so far from
thinking about what's worth defending
and what's worth valuing that we are
reverent to kind of this predial
tribalism and my hope for this you
didn't ask me what my hope is but my
hope is that we move Beyond cliches and
platitudes we move Beyond if I hear one
more person I want peace I or Justice
okay great one every great Fine By the
way when certain people say justice they
don't mean they don't traffic in the the
term in the way that sane people traffic
in that term but I want to My Hope for
this is that we have tangibles
deliverables that are actionable that we
can achieve some kind of a consensus on
doesn't have a universal consensus but
we can agree that this is how we move
forward and my my other hope for this
conference is that dissident voices are
not just allowed but fostered so what do
you think we do about this new
conference between the marxists and the
the progressives who we've all been kind
of exposing for quite some time and now
they're new alliance with the islamists
let's say because you know you mentioned
what happened at Sydney oper house where
they were CH the Jews now you can have
some I suppose you can have some sort of
intellectual argument about whether that
is free speech or not and obviously they
don't have the first amendment in
Australia like we do have in the States
but basically that they're weaponizing
all of the freedoms of the West now
against itself what do we do with that
as free speech guys okay so that that's
a that's the the question of the hour if
the criticism is all of the people who
are suddenly Pro free speech are against
people yelling Gast to
Jews which a lot of us are getting
crapped for been saying that's that's so
so so you so the first thing is you need
to have a conversation about what the
framework is Right are if one is a free
speech absolutist if one makes that
claim then you have to allow for gassing
the Jews right you have to allow for
people to not gas but claiming that
shouting or Screaming gas the Jews
although I would say that's as close as
you can possibly get for a direct call
to incitement right but even if it is in
incitement if you are truly a free
speech absolu us then anything goes you
have to allow anything right although I
guess with the the First Amendment
doesn't allow for not I guess the First
Amendment doesn't allow for direct calls
Tov this is the that's what I'm asking
you like what do we do about that little
B well that's the question the question
is you have two things you have what the
law allows and what should the law allow
and should that be the law in the first
place and unfortunately our educational
infrastructure is so damaged we're
utterly incapable of having that
conversation utterly incapable of we
can't even people are talking
about my for a former institution where
I used to work they're even against the
idea that you should you that people can
make a reasoned criticism of critical
the because they're claiming that that
is racist in and of itself in and of
itself so think about how far removed
that is from the direct incitement of
violence and just I don't have to tell
you you know this the same people who
are screaming about sugar warnings and
microaggressions have no problem with
gas the Jews kill the Jews now all of a
sudden they're free speech yeah they're
free speech the president of Harvard is
claiming Free Speech you saw it happen
at at um uh
NYU uh you know I mean this is a such
Monumental hypocrisy but going back to
your question what should we do about it
what do we do the first order of
business if a stream is being polluted
you have to stop the pollution at the
source the wrong way to think about it
is let's clean up the stream the right
way to think about it is let's stop
polluting the stream you have to you
have to stop donating to Alama first
order business yeah and we're seeing
some of that now we are and I we had a
campaign National progress Alliance of
an executive director months and months
before any of this happing stuff happen
this should be the easiest ask on planet
Earth give it to the Humane Society give
it to Dave Rubin give it to my nonprofit
give it give it to to I don't need it
give it to give it to anybody give it to
anybody but don't give it to University
because when you give it to your
University you're supporting an
indoctrination Mill you're supporting
something you're supporting an
institution whose very value values are
antithetical to Western liberal
democracy so you have to stop now for
all all those people who don't donate
anyway who who've already stopped now we
have to talk about what else we can do
to move the the needle show up literally
show nobody everybody wants to do things
virtually go up go to if you look at the
meetings videos of me there were only a
few people who show up and they're all
the same they're these these far far
left radical intersectional critical
social justice Maniacs show up be a
voice on the other side physically walk
into to your Schoolboard meetings Etc
now we're seeing more people do that
that's great so that sends a clear
message vote that's another one look at
a canidates policies uh ask questions
record things the gold standard is to do
this legally right so you have to check
if you're one party State recorded
stupid get it on film upload it to
YouTube inform people what the problem
is so here's another thing be forthright
in your speech be honest with people and
if someone has a disagreement with you
you can let friends be wrong if you have
a disagree you don't have to have
perfect ideological congruity and
everything you don't have to believe
exactly the same thing still have dinner
tonight it's shocking shock we have like
the our dinner keeps growing toight yeah
but that's a thing cuz we've lost we've
lost frenchs so what do we do do you
sense that the Silver Lining maybe is
that now that we see it so radically it
was one thing when they were like okay
America is systemically racist and
people just like all right fine where
now it's like literally like gas the or
people deserve to die do you think that
maybe they've pushed far enough now that
that the push back for the average
checked out person is now going to
appear let's say the liberal who was
just like ah whatever maybe I don't know
I I see schisms in this I I don't I
don't know how to answer that no I can't
prognosticate I have the I don't know I
do think that there is a kind of vicious
anti-Semitism that cloaks itself in
anti-zionism yeah and I I do think that
people now just simply don't have the
tools to navigate difficult problems I
think it's even worse now it's worse now
I think than it's been certainly in my
lifetime but it's interesting you know I
do think there are ways forward like if
you read Lincoln's second inaugural
address he talks about friendship and
the need for a kind of
reconciliation and if the very idea that
we're talking about a national divorce
is so insane to me it's so crazy that
we've lost the tools to deal with
problems how to navigate conversations
we people only like to hang out with
people who like things they want to move
to Blue States or red States uh look you
can move anywhere you want but that's
not helping that's actually entrenching
the division right because then you
don't even know anybody outside your
bubble so on that one I can actually
make the total counter argument which
which is that you should live in a place
that is more in line with your values
and that by someone like me leaving
California where I was in essence
literally and figuratively paying into a
system that was taking away my rights
and locking me in my home and spending
my money on nonsensical programs that
was leading to homelessness and crime
and blah blah blah that I put that aside
and said hey I will go to a place where
my values are valued and then strengthen
that I think that act that to me that's
the beauty of federalism but I I get
what you're saying in the long term then
it's like well is the United States well
I'll give you what you're looking for
you have every right to do that and you
know shellberg has written about that
for the new's policies on homk
homelessness are literally backwards San
Francisco they're Lally back shelter
first housing earn the problem in
aggregate though if everybody did that
nobody would even know someone who has a
different opinion like no one would get
to hang out you wouldn't go and that's
you wouldn't go to a dinner party in
which you'd view people who are hardcore
inveterate leftists or liberals or what
have you and then you know one of the
the reasons that people used to accept
gays is that if they knew someone who
was gay MH and so the very fact that
people will get exposed to you and see
you on a personal level that might be
great for you to move to Florida but
it's not doing the social milu any good
it's not doing the culture any good it's
not being there's a book called The Big
sort a while ago it's not doing anybody
any favors by dividing it to these
ideological tribes it's not that you
don't have a right to do that of course
you have a right to do that right no
there's there's sort of like the
granular problem of one's own life and
where do you want to live to flourish
and then there's like The Meta problem
of what do we do with a society that is
fraying and I will be the first to admit
I moved out of Portland I moved out of
Portland which I was pushing you to do
because I couldn't stand Ted wheeler I
had very serious security concerns I
moved out of Portland because I just so
fundamental disagreed with the policies
that you know the danger you call so can
I tell you a quick story so I was
driving back from a friend's house one
night Saturday night and I saw this guy
driving like a lunatic like truly
cracked out or Havey so I do what any
same person does let me tell you let me
just pause if I have to call
911 something's gone really wrong for me
to call 911 there have to be some like
genuine catastrophe right so I call 911
on hold I'm on hold so meanwhile I'm
following this guy I'm on I don't even
know how many minutes I was minutes and
minutes and minutes and minutes on on
hold then he saw me and then he started
chasing me in his car because I was on
the phone trying to call to say hey the
guy's here at this intersection there he
is he's going to kill someone he's
literally going to run someone over 911
doesn't
answer to the Hope we've see we see
systemic institutional breakdown and
that gets back to is that the part that
I think everyone's sort of shocked at at
the moment that say seven eight years
ago when we were all talking about this
mostly on college campuses and we just
like I actually always felt it was going
to spill over into real life but I don't
but I don't think most of us really
thought oh it was going to be like yes
we will have situations where the cops
will not show up like I don't know that
we all fully saw on top of now let
behead children and there's a
justification for it like like that's a
lot um yeah yes and it's a direct
consequence of the ideology did Def
follow the police FL it the the here's
the two ideas one is that the capitalism
is is inherent problem the thing that
supports your butress is capitalism is
the police so if you can get rid of the
police you can rip down the system and
then you have for example the
manifestation of homelessness in in in
La it's terrible terrible yeah Portland
is terrible uh and they spent Millions
businessmen have come in and very spend
I how I shouldn't say billions I don't
know how much but a lot of money to
clean no no they pour clean up yeah I
can't say the exact figure but the the
idea is that some people in the far left
don't want that problem solved because
they look at the manifestation of
homelessness as indicative of a problem
with the system and as long as we can
keep homelessness there we can see that
the system is corrupt and then we can
incentivize people to rip down the
system because we want social justice
right we want to remediate these larger
economic problems that we know the
socities are the capitalist structure
and that's the other thing it's the
shift that come it's the shift in
thinking that we're teaching kids that
all problems are from systems and the if
I may some one with yeah but I do want
to you may we're near we're talking in
the spirit of Arc I do want to throw out
the criticism of the right on this so
the left that I've spent a lot of time
criticism criticizing has its a unique
set of derangements that that uh it
Florence Reed from unheard calls this I
love this this line she says we are
living in a uniquely stupid age
but yeah but the right also has many
ideological problems one of those is
that while the left thinks that think
that system is systems are responsible
the right thinks that people can just
kind of pull themselves up by their own
bootstraps and as a consequence of that
we
see neighborhoods for example with tax
structures that fund local school
systems and poor neighborhoods don't get
schools that are good I think that's on
Amer Amer I think everybody should be
entitled to a public education in the
First Rate I also think that because
you're under 18 or maybe 21 you
shouldn't be denied Healthcare and I
think that the I think that the right
has fallen short on that as well
interesting and unfortunately we don't
have more time for now but like but
you're you would fund scho uh uh sorry
students before systems right 100% yeah
even though you're saying everyone
should have the right to a public
education that's a different topic
altogether but but those are not like
things where you end up hating the
person across from you hopefully it's
most like that we just have a different
where does tax money you would now hate
people uh based on some identity concern
right because you would think it's not
because you criticize this not because
you don't have the facts which is
socrates's idea but you criticize it you
don't see it because you're a bad person
so there's a kind of moral flaw in the
Lea person and we're teaching
generations of people this last question
yeah are you bullish on the future or do
you think we're we're just kind of
temporarily screwed
I really love to end inter interview
positively but I don't think I can if
you want me to be very honest I want you
to be I want you so how many minut how
many minutes do I have you got two
minutes and I'm getting answers all over
the board of this so I want you to be as
honest as possible so we know what to do
uh will we reclaim the will to do what
we we want to do I don't know one of the
things that interesting to me about
being in London is how they treat the
commons they treat the comments
incredibly well here the Subways the
systems the parks um I'm worried about
33 trillion in debt I'm worried about
the fact that I'm not even consed I'm
actually worried I'm worried about the
fact that onethird of the taxes
collected last year went to pay the
interest on the debt I'm worried that
nobody really gives a hoot about it I'm
worried about the national divorce talk
I'm worried about widescale ideological
capture of our institutions particularly
Legacy Media Legacy and institions I'm
worried about the geopolitical situation
I'm not just concerned I'm worried I'm
worried about the Israeli Palestinian
problem I don't know the solution to
that I have I if I were forced with a
gun I would say two-state solution but I
don't know I'm not an expert on that I'm
worried about that ain't happening but I
don't know that's why I don't know I'm
not AV vered and I'm not lited in that
I'm I'm worried about uh Chinese
militarization of Taiwan the
semiconductor industry I'm worried about
I'm not worried about Rogue AI or you
know kind of these X RIS things but I'm
worried that we have lost an
understanding of what makes America
great I'm worried that we don't know and
as Reagan said freedom is only one
generation away from being extinguished
I'm worried that we have forgotten why
Freedom matters why it's important
that's what I'm worried about and unless
we start to care about those things then
we can't reconstruct reason like you
can't reconstruct a civil
society so the weight loss was a little
bit about Dairy and a little bit about
stress I think that's no stress my life
has never been less stressed I feel
awesome I'm living my own dream baby
I'll see you at dinner all right look
forward to it thanks Dave appreciate it
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop screaming check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
Bell